il est arrivé à la première heure à la
permanence des républicains de dole pour
françois à des rangs du rpr puis de
l'ump et maintenant des républicains il
n'était pas question de manquer
l'élection du nouveau président du parti
auquel il adhère depuis plusieurs
décennies vous avez si donc les trois
candidats cliquez ici ici ou ici jouer
de votre choix ça rentrait de confirmer
je vous laisserai confirmé la gare à
jour très important pour les seuils de
réunir notre famille qu un peu dispersé
vrai que des choses qu'on a eu je pense
que c'est plus qu'important c'est même
un devoir parce qu'il faut qu'on se
rassemble qu'on se réunisse les
consciences de la paille de lin dans le
jura plus de 1300 adhérents étaient
appelés à voter aujourd'hui dont 500
pour la 3e circonscription celle de dole
le veux tu as bien été enregistrée merci
tous les adhérents à jour de cotisation
en 2017 les adhérents en 2016 peuvent
voter à l'élection de manière
électronique donc ils peuvent voter chez
eux sont un site internet qui est dédié
mais s'ils le souhaitent ou s'ils n'ont
pas d'accès aux outils informatiques
peuvent venir dans toutes les
permanences qui sont ouvertes dans toute
la france des permanences qui ont été
principalement fréquenté par les
adhérents les plus âgés ou les
réfractaires aux ordinateurs
au total la permanence sera accueilli
une trentaine de votants les autres
auront rempli leur devoir depuis chez
eux et c'est à paris que les résultats
de ce premier tour seront comptabilisés
pour être annoncés dans la soirée